that is
a
[Music]
that might come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers this is just something
this is just
this is just
this is just
corporate takeover censorship d banking
arrest
[Music]
corporate tankover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d-banking arrest
tyranny look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace and he's a disgrace
[Music]
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump
[Music]
that donald trump was flushing down the
toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay now
that we are up under our bodies regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango memories
eight or 11
[Music]
bring my bucks back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
[Applause]
the mangoes people
[Music]
want me to be healthy
healthy daughter want me to be healthy
and highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
well welcome everybody we have a couple
of different things on the agenda
tonight this afternoon this morning
depending on where you are
but what i don't know is where we're
sort of gonna find the first one
let me explain to you what's going on we
have a very unusual situation going on
right now
where first of all it's not really
normal that a former or current
president would be so involved in
midterm primaries like i understand
being involved in november
but donald trump has injected himself
almost like you would bleach
into a lot of the republican primaries
and he seems determined to get some kind
of a good record or whatever the case
may be and donald trump has endorsed
david perdue in the georgia republican
gubernatorial primary which is tomorrow
night
now unfortunately for david perdue he's
losing by a lot to brian kemp on the
other hand trump's own former vice
president brian kemp i'm sorry mike
pence has endorsed brian kemp so you
have another trump versus pence match-up
very unusual that you would so soon
after leaving office see a president and
vice president endorsing candidates
running against each other it's very
interesting and it could be a very bad
endorsement for donald trump in the next
few minutes
pence is rallying with brian kemp and
then at 7 p.m at the top of the hour
trump is doing a tell a rally with david
perdue so the teller rally at seven i
know exactly what we do we're actually
going to be dialing into it this is what
it sounds like if we dial in now
let's see
this meeting has not yet started please
call back later so that's going to be in
about 55 minutes
in the meantime i'm trying to find a
stream of the pen speech and i'm just
not finding it anywhere so we've got
news max oh hold on oh let's see hold on
or you go to a run-off and i think right
now purdue is trying to play the game of
getting himself let's see if they're
going to have the the event based on the
current polling maybe i'm wrong but i
don't think they're trying they're
trying to make the case to try to win
they just want to keep kemp from 50 yeah
there's no more electrifying an
inspirational speaker than mike pence of
course from primary sean president biden
raised some eyebrows during a joint
press conference
with the japanese prime minister while
speaking in tokyo okay so is newsmax
going to carry the event when it starts
which is any minute i
i really don't know
on the other hand we're also monitoring
cnn which led with a preview of the
event but now they've gotten away from
it so maybe cnn will have the event
we're also monitoring fox news which is
talk whoa who's this guy fox news
talking about bill malugan
wow um they're talking about the border
so i don't know if they're going to have
the event and then we also have this
local
thing which they're talking about the
georgia race
but
i don't know um
if they're going to have the event and
then as you can see here we have the
schedule 6 p.m pence appears with kemp
and then 7 p.m trump is in a teller
rally but it doesn't seem as though this
washington post page has
any live elements of the event so if
anybody knows for sure where we could
actually see
video of the event please let me know
otherwise we're just going to keep
monitoring these different elements
and sort of see what we what we find
what we come up with okay
i would love to carry it for everybody
and and hopefully we can find
um a stream yeah i hope i hope we get it
figured out i think i missed a super
chat where was it
uh where was that here it is do you
think the goal of banning abortion is to
stun upward mobility by forcing the
financial burden of parenthood or is it
just moralism no i think it's just
moralism
um another super chat any chance of
being able to gift multiple memberships
at once before the big sale next monday
no unfortunately that is not a feature
we're going to have implemented by
monday i just want to be real with
people and manage expectations that's on
the list for the next website revision
it looks like it's going to be a pretty
powerful revision but it is not going to
be done
by monday i will be streaming election
results tomorrow if you're just joining
us
here are
the
tomorrow we have
alabama georgia and arkansas
is it arkansas or arkansas
not sure about that in alabama ted cruz
has endorsed mo brooks which is just
weird and then georgia as we're talking
about trump has endorsed david perdue
while pence has endorsed brian kemp and
then i don't know what the hell's going
on in arkansas so um
we'll have to look at that but i will be
live tomorrow starting at 8 pm eastern
so i hope that people will join me
because it is going to be quite a scene
uh david perdue coming up okay that's
interesting
and then are they carrying the pence
rally if if anybody finds coverage of
the pence rally
please let me know oh hold on here we
are oh there it is oh what what's going
on here let's see
let's unmute here
for the person that has a record that
can beat stacey abrams in november
challenger david perdue also pulling out
all the last minutes so it looks like
they were in the room guys it looked
like they were in the room standing by
for mike pence so we we may actually
have something
uh
before you know it that's great news
great great great news
so we'll kind of flip back and forth
here and see what we get that is great i
didn't know if we were going to be able
to find a stream
so that's making me significantly more
optimistic and yes i will be live at 8pm
eastern tomorrow
um
and that'll be happening very very soon
okay let's get to a few different things
first and foremost thanks to mercolist
and crimson elric for the twitch prime
subscriptions your numbers one and two
what do i have a few elements here i
wanted to go over with you here's a very
interesting clip this is a lyft driver
who picks up a ride it's a bar owner and
her husband the bar owner makes a
comment about being happy that the
driver is white and then the driver
kicks them out
this is very very interesting check this
out
hello for jackie right he was against
the racism
yeah how are you
okay did you hear that so you might have
missed that okay that was the comment
listen to this
hello for jackie right
yeah how are you
oh you're like a white guy
you're like a white guy
excuse me
you're a normal guy you're white
white
like you speak english you speak english
sorry i'm sorry no you can get out of
the car i'm gonna cancel a ride that's
inappropriate
what it's completely inappropriate if
somebody was not white sitting in the
seat what would be the difference
are you serious she said wow you're a
white guy
so now the husband loses his mind
that's okay i'm not gonna take the ride
you guys can get out
really yeah completely inappropriate oh
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh man the husband so now i start to get
anybody who that quickly escalates to
that degree like i would never treat a
service provider like this this driver
hasn't even done anything wrong his
wife's in the wrong and you're instantly
swearing i would never treat anyone like
this and this guy's doing it 20 seconds
in
cameraman
i should punch you you're a piece of s
you're gonna threaten me that's
oh and did you hear that n-word lover
n-word lever guys
this is a cultural difference
the hell out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here no no i'm
calling the cops on you man
it's all on camera it's all on camera do
you guys own the place
is it your place
that's great everyone's gonna know
fossils last stand for black people
right
yeah [ __ ] off
so uh these are just um you know what
these people are these people are losers
pacman's a loser
um nicely done by the driver we should
yeah i don't even know anything about
the bar
um
is this the
i actually don't know what the bar is i
need well okay i don't know too much
else about this but i like it okay guys
i am liking uh what's going on there
so this stream has come
blacked out it's just gone the stream's
gone
uh
let's see if it comes back okay that's a
little bit depressing
brit hume is saying things about russia
on cnn they're in a commercial break and
newsmax is interviewing david perdue oh
let's listen to that thousand people
have voted in early voting in georgia on
the republican side and half of those
this is most noteworthy half of those
voters did not vote in 2018 so by
definition all of these polls are
excluding these people who are early
voting who did not vote wow sounds like
early voting is good all of a sudden for
a poll
you have to be in having have voted in
the last three primaries and so this has
been a miss we've talked about all along
you know matt towery is a a a very good
puzzle one of the best posters in the
country he's got another poll out this
week that shows it's only a couple of
points away from 50 percent my goal
right now is to represent the people
they're tired of a governor who has lied
to them about what happened in november
of 2020 in the election denied it
happened has covered it up and the
people are outraged about it they're
upset about crime the woke mob in the
schools they're upset about their
economy um i'm trying to get rid of the
state income tax kemp agrees with abrams
and does not want to do that so we're in
a fight down here between people and all
right so this guy's fighting and we're
standing by for the event let's see if
wolf blitzer is going to be covering it
no it doesn't seem like it and we're
watching fox and we're also watching
this very interesting the racist bar
owners that we just saw
new tonight and only on cbs 46 in
atlanta man conned out of fifteen
hundred dollars all right
we're still waiting there
um check out the yelp the yelp looks
absolutely crazy for this place this is
the bar
fossils last stand
uh one star
it can't possibly be four dollar signs
kenneth that doesn't make any sense the
business is being monitored by yelp
support team for content related to
media reports interesting
uh
let's see if we have any recent yeah
okay
there's an alert here because of what's
going on
their clam soup had a fly in it and the
restrooms had s on the walls and floor
this place is horrible i had a burger
and fries and it was disgusting i threw
up after my second bite also the owners
are racist
oh that's the best angel wrote staff was
rude owners racist food disgusting
effing racists i hope you burn in hell
blm
attempted to order a drink but was hard
to communicate due to the noise level of
the clan meeting going on behind me
would not recommend if you're a person
of color
zero stars it's the openly racist saying
the n-word with ease and threatening
drivers over their open bigotry that got
me yeah that's that's fair
um
yeah all of these guys are in the last
in the last couple days so melting down
yelp completely melting down for these
folks and that's uh
that's probably gonna leave a mark is my
um my my expectation there
um continuing to monitor all of these
different streams we expect the event to
get underway
pretty soon
um thanks to margot cabot for the twitch
prime subscription you're number three
today and i really appreciate that
uh
okay
let's see if i have anything else over
here
we are going to continue okay so we did
racist driver that's done
now by the way there's this big movement
there's this hip movement now that says
they're for free speech that would say
it's unfair now
the campaign that's been launched
against these people
i would never use the n-word
period even in front of people i'm i'm
like comfortable with
the husband knew the lyft driver for 30
seconds and called him an n-word lover
okay
this is not a contrived smear campaign
these are disgusting people
oh our is everyone irredeemable now
because of something you said on the
internet now that this is about how
you're treating people in the real world
okay and they're free to say whatever
they want the lyft driver is free to
record what goes on in his own vehicle
free to publish it people are free to
evaluate it some people might like
people who use the n-word and they'd say
we found a racist bar i love it let's go
and support the racist bar great
you can do that if you like it if you
like supporting businesses where the
owners
haphazardly use the n-word
here's a bar for you
and if you don't like it you can choose
not to go okay now
the review stuff
reviews are freedom of speech
if you didn't really go
yelp's policy is you're supposed to have
really been a customer and comment on
the food and so
yelp is completely within their terms of
service to say we're removing reviews
that are
like this right yelp could do that
yelp could do that but everybody has had
the freedom to speak and everybody has
to suffer the consequences of the speech
that they've made that's it's just what
it is you know if listen
i i don't know if you guys remember but
i told you not long ago about i was at a
restaurant
and i was out at a patio it was a
beautiful evening i had a delightful
uh
meal and whatever and when i was leaving
someone
said
hey pacman
and i turned and they go
you jew imperialist bastard okay this
was in a public setting
now
i could have responded it was a woman
who did this i could have responded and
and used the c word or the b word or
you know said
imag imagine like that i said get back
in the kitchen where you belong or
something like that and it had been
filmed
right imagine that public place
the filming would have been fine
it would have been her speech it would
have been my speech that could have been
published online
and all of a sudden i'm guessing many of
you people
would have said oh my god
david pakman called some woman
the c word or the b word or told her to
get in the kitchen i'm canceling my
membership
i mean that i had my speech she had her
speech and then people on the internet
can say wow the consequences to david
doing that it's going to be that i
cancel my membership and i would have
had to deal with that right i mean it
would have been the consequences of my
speech i i don't know it's um
yeah
i would have said it's the globalish do
i have that
where is it globalist internationalist
socialists unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right now what i actually did is i just
walked away
so anyway this is this is the world we
live in unfortunately and uh it's sort
of
it is what it is as the kids like to say
as we stand by here presumably
presumably
for the mike pence event super chat keep
spreading truth and decency david sur
says adam gingrich well adam i want to
thank you adam just did an amazing thing
adam is gifting subscriptions on my
website adam gingrich just gifted one
and adam gingrich just gifted a second
one and kevin gouldy gifted a membership
those are numbers four five and six
today
really easy to gift memberships okay
when you're signing up on the website
and by the way even with coupon codes
like for example use the you can use the
coupon code obama obama that drops the
price down
uh
ordinarily what's going on here there it
is drops the price down if you check
this box this is a gift
i will then give away
the memberships to people that want them
let me do that right now i've just got
to pull up my list of people who want
memberships
uh and the first three today
are up let's see here oh nope that's uh
hold on carlos martinez
inez williamson
and
one person requested a ton of them and
i'm just deleting all of them i'm sorry
i apologize for wasting everybody's time
with this
the third one is
oh dear god someone oh we're blocking
this person yeah we turned on
verification after someone the same
person said they wanted a bunch of
membership someone going by the name bob
but obviously we know that's fake
hold on who is the next one
taryn singer there it is terence singer
is number three
also thank you to 79 carlio for the
twitch prime subscription you're number
seven today appreciate everybody thank
you very very much as we continue to
stand by here
um for the pence rally
um
should be any moment i guess it's what
they're telling me
okay one other super chat here david
have you heard trump pulled away from
endorsing purdue they're doing a tele
rally tonight
trump purdue where did he pull away
i'm not seeing that
uh they're doing a telerally tonight so
i think he still supports him
gamer
but we'll see if the if the thing
doesn't end up happening tonight then i
think we will know okay let's see what
else we've got kim iverson i don't know
how many you know about you know about
kim iverson she's sort of in the toolsie
line as far as i understand where like
at one point she i i guess claimed to be
on the left but then she appeared on the
hill
rising
and
just says crazy stuff like crazy crazy
stuff she's sort of gone the direction
of like jimmy dore and people like that
she sent me a tweet
so i don't know how many of you know
kim.com okay kim.com is
a tech guy formerly of mega upload he
follows me i follow him i believe he now
lives in new zealand
kim.com posted
um
this thing he posted in a prank call to
george w bush admits the u.s broke its
promise to russia not to expand nato
eastward because times have changed and
the u.s was adjusting to the times now
george w bush did get pranked
i responded in reality that was never
agreed to it was mentioned verbally but
not part of any final signed agreements
we've covered this on the show quite a
bit which is the talking point is oh
um
putin's right to invade ukraine
because there was an agreement signed
that said the that nato would not expand
eastward and that's not true it was
verbally mentioned by james baker i
believe it was it was not part of any
final actual agreement great so kim.com
comes back and says not true a
memorandum was exchanged russia would
never have agreed to give up east
germany if it wasn't for the u.s
guarantee not to expand eastwards
and i said
i'm more than willing to have my mind
changed but in all of the research i did
i was not able to find any evidence of
that and i posted this screenshot such
an agreement was never made nato says on
its website
nato's door has been open to new members
since it was founded in 1949 as that and
that has never changed so in comes kim
iverson and says it doesn't matter if
the agreement
was official or not
it was understood
handshake agreement and the u.s is now a
bunch of lying shysters i think she
means shysters now i was going to
respond and then i realized
i'm an idiot if i respond because you're
you're this is just bad faith this is
the
you know tulsi jimmy dore sort of line
it sort of does matter if it's official
if it's not official it's not actually
an agreement
it's like sort of saying like you know i
had an unofficial contract with my car
dealer but then like they gave me a
piece of paper and it didn't say any of
that stuff that they told me
unofficially and then i signed it and
now i want the stuff that they verbally
said it's not i mean it's just not an
agreement then
i don't know my mortgage broker told me
i was getting a one percent mortgage but
then on the disclosure it said four
percent and then on the paperwork it
said four percent and my lawyer told me
it's four percent and i signed it and
then i got a bill and it says four
percent but they had mentioned it was
one percent
oh oh okay but so
the agreement said four percent yeah
and your lawyer said your mortgage is
four percent yeah and you signed it
saying i understand this is four percent
yeah
okay so what are we really talking about
here
anyway so this is um you know there's a
contingent that is that is taking this
approach
uh and what what can you do you know
this is uh this is the direction they're
going so that's that
um we're gonna get to marjory taylor
green in a moment but i do want to keep
an eye on all these different streams
just to see what's going on
baby formula has arrived
they're in commercials here
i doubt i don't know that newsmax will
cover the speech necessarily because
they're i think they're pro-trump and
pence has endorsed trump's uh the guy
that trump did not endorse
so we're going to see okay marjorie
taylor green has a new conspiracy theory
some call it a hypothesis i call it a
conspiracy theory that democrats want to
turn your kids gay
let's listen
if anyone who was a democrat
steps out a line because they've decided
they can't go along with the horrible
disgusting and failing ways of the
democrats and they actually see the
light see the truth and they go you know
i'm going to try voting republican
because these people over here make
sense they like everybody they think our
constitution is for everyone they don't
want to turn your kids gay and and have
you know transgender and they don't want
to kill babies in the way they don't
want to have transgender
and they really want a thriving economy
they want everyone to have money and
they want everyone to have a job and we
kind of care about the border so people
step out you know they start voting
republican like elon says he's going to
do
and what happens
oh boy they come after you they did it
to president trump we've seen it done to
celebrities
do i now
i of obviously we all know
democrats don't want to turn your kids
gay but here's my question
does anybody know
what they would say about why democrats
would want to turn your kids gay like i
don't even understand what the motive
would be why would democrats want more
people to be gay i just i and and i i
know that i'm asking you guys something
difficult which is it's of course not
true
but what is their explanation for why
democrats would want to do that does
anybody have any idea
what's the benefit to more gay people
depopulation
because gay people vote for democrats oh
interesting democrats want to turn
people gay
because when you turn them gay they
become democrats
yeah if that's the best explanation
they've got that's pretty damn bad
replacement theory of some kind yeah
yeah i i don't know
i don't know
okay anyway it doesn't make any sense
few other super chats gamer asks david
sir where did the globalist conspiracy
theory start was that supposed to be
anti-semitic conspiracy theory used by
the extreme right wing you know i
actually don't know the answer to that
uh history of globalist
conspiracy theory
oh it's it's considered a new world
order
the oranges are considered to be new
world order and it's similar to
globalist
um
let's see
oh now it is mentioned that some of the
underlying principles of new world order
conspiracy theory comes from the
protocols of the elders of zion which is
an anti-semitic canard first public
published in russia in 1903
and whose printing was funded
eventually by henry ford the guy from
ford
this is why i will not buy a ford
vehicle
and because i think that they're
terrible cars but also because of the
henry ford thing so just a little bit of
a side note for the kids in the audience
kawthorne hinted at dark magga is this
similar to the dark elves as mentioned
by tolkien i believe it is
i believe it is yeah
very good point chakuseki
um
let's see what else we have going on
here
so far still no coverage of the pence
event let me do one more scan through
and the trump event starts in about 25
minutes too
let me see if i can find this
so this would be pence
kemp
and let's see if we have anything live
here
uh no just my stream that's interesting
yeah i don't know um
maybe pbs let's see if pbs newshour
might be carrying it
pbs
they're certainly they are not okay so
we'll keep standing by here for the
pence event
um and see where when it where or when
it might be starting
yep
okay
let's continue with a few other things
here
um oh this is super interesting so i you
guys may know that we are rapidly
heading towards 1.5
hold on a second we are heading towards
1.5
million subscribers on youtube and i
said you know let me know ideas for
things that could be done
lucas wrote in with the following offer
david sir in your last few episodes
you've been talking about what to do to
reach 1.5 million subscribers faster and
teased with the idea of dyeing your hair
or shaving your head as a sign of
selfless service and given how much the
mango intro song of the stream makes me
unreasonably happy i'm willing to have a
mango tattooed if whoops hold on a
second
if we get to your established goal
before the midterm elections i'd go even
further to promise to do it alongside of
a cartoon stencil version of you with
the phrase i love mangoes too we have
someone willing
to get a tattoo of me saying i love
mangoes too if we accelerate our path to
1.5 million subscribers which is pretty
wild now a mango tattoo it just looks
like an egg right i mean it's
i don't know how you do it and make it
clear it's a mango super relevant i know
i'll send you the picture of the tattoo
if indeed the goal is accomplished kind
regards from a fellow argentinian so
lucas is coming up with an idea of
getting a mango tattoo
if we accelerate our race to 1.5 million
subscribers on youtube pretty wild stuff
and meanwhile meanwhile i do think it's
important to mention that our friend
kenji jay kenji lopez alt who follows me
on instagram he had an incredible video
about the proper way to eat a mango it's
just 60 seconds i do want to show
everybody
hey everyone it's kenji i'm in hawaii
and i'm going to show you how to eat a
mango this is big time stuff so
this works best
when you're outdoors beach is best park
will do you know
over a kitchen sink is okay too uh you
need a really ripe mango this is a
hayden it'll work with any of these sort
of small soft mangoes so hayden if
you're on the mainland like a champagne
antaufo
honey mango you start at the pit end and
you uh
sorry at the button end and you peel it
off in strips like this look at this
you can scrape those bits with your
teeth
like an artichoke i'm not gonna show you
all that but eventually you get all the
all that skin off
and you scrape it all with your teeth
look at that
and then you're left with this and this
you can just eat like an apple
look at that
wait a
it's messy it's no waste uh but it's the
best way i know
how to eat a mango pretty powerful stuff
folks all right so there is that and uh
it is it is wild wild wild what people
are doing we do need diamond and silk
here okay jovan hutton pull my finger
says sir could we affect the citizen's
arrest of 45. uh i mean you can try it
if you think it's safe but i i have a
hard time imagining that's gonna work
gamer wants to know the oranges of the
mangoes all right let's give away some
subscriptions thank you to jen here
crowbars forever and bionic bill new
members eight nine and ten today via
twitch prime now look at this we're a
bunch of memberships just dumped in
kyoko awaya who is our great friend from
tokyo has gifted a membership amy price
has gifted a membership kyoko just
gifted
kyoko just gifted another membership
kyoko has gifted another membership
kathy gavel
has gifted one
simon reed has gifted a membership
and simon reed has gifted a second
membership that's six putting us at 16
those free memberships go to
jesse edelen
michael krupka
scott myron shane moore matthew hogan
and helena svenson
if you would like a free membership just
fill out the short form at
davidpakman.com
free membership if you can afford to
give away a membership we have
449 people currently waiting for
memberships sign up at joinpackman.com
and check the box is this a gift but
much like with oxygen masks on airplanes
you put yours on first then you help
others around you i would encourage you
to
first get a membership for yourself
and then get memberships for others
around you that's just my recommendation
and speaking of which i want to say
thanks to nick alfred
who just got himself a membership that's
number 17 today
uh okay let's see it looks like we've
got the pen stuff going
his former boss pence is campaigning for
the incumbent governor of georgia one of
former president trump's top political
targets show the rally international
correspondent kristen holmes is in
atlanta for us watching all of this
unfold kristen trump and pence are
backing competing candidates in the
georgia governor's race tomorrow all of
this on the eve of the primary things
are getting rather intense where you are
right
that's right well if they are getting
intense as you mentioned the former vice
president mike pence currently holding a
rally for incumbent governor brian kemp
show the rally this not only defies
president trump you have to remember
trump is not just supporting kemp's
opponent uh former senator david perdue
but he actually recruited him to run
against kemp and bashed kemp over and
over again for not overturning the 2020
election so a lot of heated rhetoric
back and forth here we heard from
trump's spokesperson who insulted pence
for coming to the state not mincing
words saying now desperate to chase his
lost relevance pence is parachuting into
races hoping someone is paying attention
so again this has turned into somewhat
of a proxy war trump for his part not
holding an in-person rally in the final
days of this election but he did host a
telerally he's doing that later tonight
and he called in to a radio show to
support trump but this is she's a
support purdue but this is a huge moment
for the former president for two big
reasons one is that he really wants to
beat former incumbent governor brian
kemp he has poured over 2.5 million
dollars into this election from his
super pac this is more money than he has
spent on any other race in this midterm
season and the other it goes to show how
far trump's big lie will play and how it
will resonate in the midterm elections
this has been a pillar of purdue's
campaign he has really gone all in on
the big lie and so far it doesn't look
good for trump or purdue he has been
trailing in the polls
if it is any indication as to how kemp
is feeling going into tomorrow we can
note that over the last several days he
has spent a lot of time campaigning and
hitting one person particularly hard and
that person is stacey abrams who will be
the democratic candidate for the
governorship in the fall he certainly is
all right kristen thank you very much uh
we're showing our viewers some live
pictures now coming in from georgia
you can see over there brian kemp on the
stage with mike pence mike pence is
about to speak uh he's strongly
endorsing the current government a
little bit georgia brian kemp we'll
listen in and uh and and see what he has
to say we'll get back to that shortly
but right now i want to be joined by our
cnn senior commentator john kasich the
first right so republican government
doesn't seem like they're going to have
some of it so i think we'll stay here i
don't think anybody else
has any oh hold on is this even live
this hyundai commercial seems like it's
been on forever um
okay i think we're gonna stick here this
is our best shot at getting any of that
and then the trump telerally starts in
20 minutes anyway okay so so we're going
to stick with it super chats juni david
why do today's republicans claim to be
for free trade and the expansion of the
economy but also favor tariffs which
most economists say hurt the us economy
because they don't actually have
principles
they just say whatever they can at the
time
that they believe will be politically
expedient there's no real economic
principle underlying any of it
tech strickle i'm unsure how to find
information for the trump rally as far
as far as how to log on if you can
provide me with a place to get the info
it would be a great help so here's the
info on the um
trump event
it's a tele rally so we're going to be
dialing in
let's see what happens if we call in now
this meeting has not yet started
please call back later okay yeah so you
just dial in that's all it is
uh it's it's pretty freaking pathetic
but it is what it is i want to say thank
you to a couple of other people very
serious man and beth graham have just
teed up twitch
prime subscriptions which i really
appreciate also want to say thanks to
matt dever just signed up on my website
and anthony kraus just signed up on my
website new members 20 and 21
really really appreciate everybody's
support the live streams continue and we
will be live tomorrow night with
election results very important election
results
um
we will see whether trump or pence win
essentially
and uh it's gonna be wild it's gonna be
quite wild and we are cnn is moments
away from showing some of this rally
that pence is doing pence not exactly an
electric speaker as many of you know
tgq newsweek there is no confirmation at
the time
of writing that pence georgia rally will
be live streamed right yeah we know we
knew that
we might have some trouble finding
the uh rally
but
cnn is about to show some of it so
that'll give us an idea thanks also to
matt dever for gifting a subscription
that is number 22
that subscription goes to michael
hernandez
who requested a free membership at
davidpakman.com
free membership as we wait here for the
pence rally and the trump rally let's
look at
a couple a couple of uh voicemails
and see what we've got
um
let's see
hey david i'm just watching your most
recent uh video
and you're covering madison cothorn
and uh it seems like you left out like a
really crucial detail not only was
madison cosborne in bed
naked with another man that man was
related to him yeah so i the reason i
didn't mention
the the cousin thing is because i've
read conflicting reports about it
conflicting oh wait nbc news
youtube live people are telling me the
nbc live news now
has the stream
let's see
let's take a look at that
that not just on the republican side
because of these highly
is it is the thing over or what's going
on here
anybody know
no it can't possibly be over
so in terms of people who are looking at
this race and finding it to be very
important that is certainly high here
take a look at what they had to say
i guess it's over
once fair elections and
kemp didn't seem to want fair elections
before i mean he shouldn't done anything
illegal i mean just legal means to
help straighten out the election
did you support president trump i did
and does his criticism of the governor
i don't like that
i don't like it at all
so hallie that's just a sample of people
that i talked to both supporting the
governor and supporting david perdue
i've got to say you also see the
difference in their campaign rallies you
know uh purdue held a rally a press
conference today 2020 was again
central focus a big issue there but when
you talk to brian kemp when you listen
to him he talks about his record he
talks about bills that he signed into
law he talks about being the first state
to reopen after covet several things he
does not talk about 2020 donald trump
and really he doesn't even talk about
david perdue until sometimes at the end
hallie that's interesting i wonder if
he's talking even more about stacey
abrams these days playing especially
considering it looks as though i mean
she's all but certain to be the
democratic pick for the governor's race
she would be his general election
matchup if he's not already looking past
tomorrow and look into november
you know what's interesting if there is
one thing that unites the two kemp and
purdue it's their
opposition to stacey abrams that is the
one thing that really does unite them
you kind of hear that they know they're
against going to bat over who is going
to be the one that's more likely to beat
her in november in fact when you go back
to the first debate between the two
well i guess we don't really know
whether the thing is already over it if
this is live it seems to have ended cnn
said they were going to take it live
coming up so i don't know what the hell
is going on uh but we're gonna watch it
and then in 15 minutes the trump
telerally starts so we will we will see
um super chat asks how am i not more
cynical following politics suggests to
me that we're on a quick downward spiral
yeah no i don't i don't know
i'm just not cynical by nature i guess
uh
it's it's uh yeah i don't know what to
tell you about that
i want to say thanks to matt dever for
gifting another subscription
and juan the troll man has gifted
another subscription
and hillary lee
has gifted another subscription that's
three putting us at 25
those go to
carson bannister
megan hoopel
and tony wheeler thank you very much i
appreciate that and we'll stick with cnn
now presumably they will be back
momentarily we were listening to
a various voicemails
let's see what else we've got
uh
the eggman
hey dave if dr amit oz loses in
pennsylvania trump will definitely say
that uh the democrats cheated or
somebody cheated him and if you give a
colonoscopy
i'll volunteer i'm in my 50s and i've
been putting it off so hello brother
yeah uh what the eggman is referring to
there is that someone wrote in and said
david
you should do a colonoscopy
when you get to 1.5 million subscribers
and there was some grammatical ambiguity
because
usually it's the
gastroenterologists who do the
colonoscopy
and it's the patient who gets the
colonoscopy so it was it wasn't clear
whether the viewer was saying i should
receive a colonoscopy or i should
perform one and i'm not licensed uh my
specialty is ophthalmology just like
rand paul i wouldn't be
i wouldn't be qualified
to do
um such a procedure unfortunately
okay
let's see what else we've got
um
oh man
there's this is kind of kind of a weird
voicemail hi david thank you so much for
that advertisement about real bamboo
um you've really kind of revolutionized
my life i've been using regular toilet
paper but now i use a stick of bamboo
and i okay yeah we're gonna get away
from that that's that's not so good
um
it's bamboo based toilet paper it's not
sticks of bamboo that would that would
just be crazy all right let's see if
we're going to the pence event yet no we
are not doesn't look like we're going
over there yet
so we're continuing to stand by
um oh let's see also what happens if we
try calling into the trump rally
this meeting has not started yet we hope
you will enjoy listening until it starts
see if we can do anything with this
okay um
let's not wait on hold for the rally so
far
let's just not wait yeah let's let's
just now wait on hold we'll call back
the dude says david sir do you think the
progressive wins in australia could be a
positive sign for upcoming elections god
i hope so and if they start charging
child support at conception i bet guys
opinions will change pretty quickly
thanks yeah a long segment today about
the
labor victory in australia over the
weekend check out that clip for sure
it's uh it's quite an interesting one
quite an interesting one
let's see if i have any other voicemails
for people
um
what else do we have here
hi david am i the only one who thinks
that john federer and stroke is like
really really suspicious like really he
gets a stroke right before the election
like i mean would you put it past
someone like dr oz or like any trumpet
to not try to like kill their opponent
oh
the caller seems to be saying is it
possible that the stroke was caused by
some kind of
uh poisoning or something like that by
by mement no i don't believe there is no
evidence for that whatsoever
so you know we're going to try to stick
to the facts
on this program
um
oh the eggman called in about the
buffalo shooting as well
hey dave so there's a memorial at that
tops grocery store where 10
black people were murdered by that white
kid and anyway all these people are
going there um the whole team of buffalo
bills have gone there and dropped off
teddy bears and cried and said things
and
thousands of people famous people
of all these people that are going there
a third to a half of them watch fox news
and support tucker carlson and our
right-wing buffalo bill sports nut jobs
that don't even realize that their own
attitude support and and confirmation of
these ideas on fox caused this kid to do
that
these people
are victims of their own frankenstein
and they don't even know what they're
creating
how do you let people realize
that they are the partial cause of this
uh tragedy that they're
that they're crying about it's
it's dry it's driving me nuts um
anyway
shalom brother have a great week yeah uh
what beautifully said by the eggman
i mean some of them don't realize
and then others just won't accept so i
think there's a couple there's a couple
different things there
um
let's see if i have any other
voicemails here
i've got a super chat interested in this
election says haley i believe the only
reason georgia has such a clean 2020 is
because everyone knew how suspicious it
was
that kemp beat abrams in 2018 can he
maintain a clean election again i i
don't have any idea and i want to just
be careful i i'm not assuming it won't
be clean i just don't know i don't know
the specifics of what's happening on the
ground there
and so um
we're just going to have to wait and see
but hoping for a completely clean
election of course of course of course
of course
um
this seems like an unhinged voicemail
let's see
um
[Music]
of doctor eyes
and uh steven crowder uh give me a break
i'm so bored with them
that's troy york let's see if i have
something like a little more uh
a little more reasonable here
um
let's see if i have something
interesting
the troll man juan called in let's see
what he had to say
hey david i have a question
why is it that it appears
to me exclusively
that mass shootings
are much more newsworthy
or
more frequently seen
on my youtube video
recommendations and even on the news in
general
during in this case
the biden administration
that you know it's that's so anecdotal
it's like
even if it were true that juan was
seeing more videos about mass shootings
it really tells us like nothing about
anything but it's yeah i don't know man
and
apparently not as much during the trump
administration i already did the
research and yes there's my shootings
throughout the year no matter what
president is
in office
is it possible that the reason you see
it more
is because
perhaps
they believe that
something could be done about it because
there is a democratic party in office
that it is such a reach the calls from
juan which i love
are often
so they they take
an unfounded assertion
and then make conclusions off of it and
it's all speculative and it's all it's
all just wacky oh hold on a second i'm
told this is the pence rally these of
the last century
they want to stifle the liberties the
generations of americans have fought to
defend
but you know the future belongs to
freedom
and when you vote for brian kemp
tomorrow
you will say yes to a future of freedom
here in georgia you'll say yes to our
most cherished values
at the heart of everything we hold there
and when you say yes
to governor brian kemp tomorrow you will
send a deafening message all across
america that the republican party is the
party of the future
and we will ban men
what an inspiring speaker
it's not just about us but it's about
our kids
and our grandkids
you know since we've last seen each
other i had some
new developments in my life
we moved back to the hoosier state
i bought a john deere tractor
and i became a grandfather for the first
time
what charisma
and i can tell by the looks on your
faces when i said that
you know what i'm talking about
we're not just fighting for governor
brian kemp we're not just fighting
for the conservative agenda here in
georgia we're fighting for our kids
and our grandkids
fighting for the america
that they deserve
an america grounded in freedom
and in our highest ideals
so i want to encourage you to leave from
here and
make sure and get out and vote please
georgia
vote to renominate governor brian kemp
for four more years in the republican
primary
that cadence vote to renominate brian
kemper
and remember
and remember friends don't let friends
vote alone
grab a family member grab a friend get
out and vote in that republican primary
and finally i would say to you finally
in these challenging times
where it seems like that
there's more that divides us in this
country than ever before
i will tell you that i don't really see
it that way
i'll always believe that there will
always be more that unites us in america
than could ever divide us and chief
among those things
is faith
and so i want to encourage you
if from time to time you bow the head
and bend the knee
i want you to do that before those polls
close tomorrow pray for the results i
want you to pray for governor brian kemp
right
first lady marty and the girls
i want you to pray
that they would have the courage and the
conviction to carry forward this
campaign and the opportunity that they'd
be given to do that
i also want you to pray for all the
people of georgia right
we have the opportunity to renew
leadership this fall in georgia that
will continue to lead and inspire the
nation
and pray with confidence
knowing that
as the bible tells us
if his people who are called by his name
will humble themselves and pray and turn
he'll do like he's always done
what a terrible speaker this state in
this nation
he'll hear from heaven
and he'll heal this land
this one nation
under god
indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all
so let's get out there
let's support governor brian camp and
send him on the road to victory this
november
and there he goes
[Music]
sinister
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so there's pence i mean
completely uninspirational in every way
incredibly moving and just an
electrified audience you know they're
going to vote and they're going to vote
hard because it's just so
incredible i want to say thank you to
hillary lee who has just gifted another
subscription on my website to a lucky
recipient actually two hillary's dumping
in memberships left and right that's
numbers 26 and 27 want to say thank you
to joanna wendy and martin rodriguez
okay we're about to call into the trump
rally actually let's call in now let's
see what's going on
this meeting has not started yet we hope
you will enjoy listening until it starts
[Music]
okay
so i am actually
gonna stay on now
is the audio mix though can you can we
can you guys hear it i hear a different
mix than you here is this an okay level
for me to talk over
does this work
trump's late yeah
you can't hear it at all
okay let me turn it up a little
how about that
i'm still hearing it it might be too low
for you guys
still a little bit okay hold on let's
see i'm gonna go up more
how about now
can you hear the call sound
thank you for joining the telerally
is it starting
and i'll be your moderator this evening
this is at the conclusion of president
trump's remarks we'll be asking a
special poll question so please stay on
the line
it is now my pleasure to introduce david
perdue wow this is interesting thank you
lindy folks thank you for dialing in
tonight we have a very special guest
this is the second one of these talent
rallies that he has done for us he also
came to commerce georgia yeah trump
couldn't even be bothered to go to
georgia
came out and spent the night with us and
just really fired people up spent the
night the purpose of tonight is to hear
from our ex-president tell us how
important this race is and how important
it is to get out and vote but first let
me remind everybody president donald
trump gave us the best economic
turnaround in u.s history after eight
years of the lowest output
economic output under barack obama
president trump turned this around made
the world safer for us and got us out of
a war so
i am so grateful for his support and
endorsement without further ado it's my
honor and pleasure to get to introduce
to you tonight the 45th president of the
united states president donald donald j
trump mexico
well thank you very much david i
appreciate it very much and i have to
just uh maybe
add something to what you just said our
country i don't think has ever been in
worse shape than it is right why is this
so funny horrible
uh situation that took place in
afghanistan with the taliban giving them
75 85 billion
how a governor deals with afghanistan i
don't know we lost 13 soldiers many
horribly horribly wounded and left many
people behind american people behind
horrible situation but when you look at
inflation you look at all of the
problems it's uh it's disgraceful and
tomorrow was so critical it's a primary
it's something that we
have to win we want to win and
we have a
governor that's done the worst job of
any governor
in probably decades on election
integrity
i'd like you to get out and what trump
means is the guy didn't give me georgia
purdue
in the republican gubernatorial primary
so important david is
the only candidate who can beat stacey
abrams because i don't believe kemp can
do it he's got too many people in the
republican party that will refuse to
vote that's just not going to go out
after what they did to two senators and
to
a presidential
election what he did
should have been so different and you
see it all just go see 2 000 mules and
there's plenty of there's
plenty other things beyond that so if
you don't
want to let stacey abrams radicalize
your children and plunder your wealth
and
all of the other things even today what
she said is
unbelievable she's saying what a
horrible place georgia is you take a
look at her statement today she just
made it a little while ago just came
over the wires
the wires that's strange but it's going
to be very very hard
for anybody but david david is going to
be able to win and win easily because
he's got the spirit
but he's running against kemp
who lied as a rhino
who would along with his friend
raffensberger allowed the georgia
election to be rigged and to be stolen
it was rigged and it was stolen take a
look at
the movie take a look at whatever you
want to look at there are many different
ways and it's a shame the radical left
ran a massive illegal ballot harvesting
scam right under kemp's nose and
raffensberger by the way jody heist
great guy vote for him by the way if
you're just joining us we're on a phone
call with trump votes kemp was given
this indisputable evidence by the people
that drew the vote and he refused to do
anything he didn't want to do anything
which was incredible to everybody kemp
and raffensberger personally paved the
way for the
disaster that our country's right now in
they allowed stacey abrams to bully them
into an outrageous consent decree how
they ever
got that signed and why the republicans
or anybody would sign such a thing
but it was signed in a disaster
gutting georgia's voter integrity laws
and allowing left-wing organization
if they let me ask a question what
should i ask the ballots and unsecured
drop boxes drop boxes all over the place
stacey abrams totally dominates brian
kemp
and that's why nobody can understand
what he did nobody someday we'll figure
it out but nobody unders i can
understand why
he did that why
you look at uh david perdue is so great
and brian kemp why he
did the things for stacey abrams and for
the democrats
kemp and raffensberger also allowed
georgia officials to take
45 million dollars from mark zuckerberg
used to improperly boast mostly democrat
turnout if you look at it mostly
democrats
brian kemp is truly
a embarrassment to the republican party
because of what's taken place
in your great state georgia and david
will make a massive upgrade as your
governor as a senator he was a highly
respected gentleman in washington i can
tell you because he was a senator while
i was there they called them and nobody
did so much as we did
we cut taxes we rebuilt the military we
created a strong border with the
strongest border in history and now we
have the worst border in history and
that includes with respect to drugs
just by biden coming in it became a bad
border and a corrupt political machine
and he will not rest until everything in
our elections is free
fair and honest he'll eliminate george's
income tax cut regulations and he'll buy
american and he'll hire american
david will fight critical race theory
put parents back in charge of georgia
and he will keep men out of women sports
as you know david's pro-life he's
pro-second amendment which is by the way
totally under siege pro border security
pro police and he's 100
mega
so i take this time tonight i appreciate
a lot of people on the phone right now
but
i have
absolute great this is apparently the
most people that have ever been on a
phone call fantastic
governor so if you can tomorrow get out
and vote election day get out and vote
for david perdue you will not be
disappointed you'll look back
in years to come and you'll say that was
a great vote just as i hope you feel
that you vote for me was a great vote we
had our country at a level that it's
probably never been at before in fact i
can say that it has never been at before
so thank you all very much get out and
vote david perdue and david i'll turn it
back to you thank you
god bless you mr president history will
be uh very favorable on your legacy
about how you turned our country around
we miss you we know we're not done yet
and thank you for being there for me
listen you know who your friends are
when you get in the fight and uh i count
you as a dear friend mr president thank
you for operators are standing by free
shipping thank you david thank you very
much
so everyone on the call thank you for
joining us tonight please stay on the
line uh there are a couple questions we
would like to ask you i'm going to turn
you back over take just a second it
would really help us as we're going into
tomorrow but let me close it with this
i'll i'll come back just a minute but
please uh stay on the line and lindy
i'll turn it back over to you to ask
your question
thank you david i appreciate that and
thank you president trump for a
wonderful message
please use your phone's keypad to answer
the poll question oh here we go here's
your poll question
can president trump count on you to vote
for david perdue for governor tomorrow
tuesday may 24th nope
press one for yes
press two for no
press three for undecided
we look forward to hearing from the
great people thanks
again i just voted no question this
evening is
can president trump count on you to vote
for david perdue for governor tomorrow
tuesday may 24th
press one for yes press two for no
press three for undecided you can use
your phone's keypad to answer the poll
question
hmm thank you
stayed in the poll question david do you
have any closing remarks
i do lindy thank you for moderating this
and everyone that joined the call i
think you can see how sincere president
trump is now this race is bigger than me
it's bigger than brian camp it's about
the future of our country if we want a
republican conservative back in the
white house in 24 and we want a senate
majority back this year we have to win
this governor's race in georgia brian
kemp has divided our party and he cannot
beat stacey abrams thank you so much for
being involved please go out and vote if
you haven't voted if you have voted god
bless you thank you for that but in the
meantime make sure you and all your
friends go out and vote tomorrow thank
you god bless you good night
we appreciate you spending your evening
with us
please visit votepurdue.com evening i'm
getting off the call it was eight
minutes long including trump's speech
spending your evening with us what the
hell is going on there
what a rally huh
really really going to inspire lots of
people to go out and vote what a
complete and total mess just absolutely
bizarre
um
okay well that was really bad
uh i don't even know what to make of
that that was just terrible okay i did
want to mention
i am now on troth central as you know
donald trump got the name of his own
social media platform wrong truth
essential yeah i'm on the platform you
know what's really funny
i somehow have over 500 followers on
truth
even though
i mentioned it like once i think i
tweeted about it once
so if you want to follow me on there
basically what we're doing is just oh
you know
my friends you guys
just post positive responses to my
comments
even though like the people on the
platform are pretty freaking nuts
um
i posted this check out some of the
comments
wait a second states
who's the current president of the
united states
who's the current president well
i guess um i guess it's a it's a funny
it's a funny question is it really
yeah i do think it we live in a very
interesting time
where
um
we have there's forces beyond our
visibility
that uh like supernatural supernatural
not supernatural oh there's there's okay
i was disappointed when he said no so
anyway check out some of the responses
here in the comments let's see
um do you know jesus trump would know
him more than you and his friends libs
like the devil
abort the libs hashtag
if you'd like a list of bible verses
that apply to trump being an antichrist
let me know
libs need to get off here go back to
cancel culture twitter
jesus loves trump and they were friends
that's why he's president and not baeden
can you make picture of trump and jesus
hanging out like
friends hmm
oh this is a satire account let's see
hm i actually can't tell if it's satire
that's interesting
it's a really weird website
anyway if people are curious about it it
does look just like twitter let's look
at another one
um oh so i posted
some guy on this platform told me every
time trump glitches like oranges of the
investigation dropbox it's a deliberate
signal to those who know what to listen
for reminds me of a viewer who was
convinced i was sending the messages by
blinking my eyes in morse code
your smug dismissal of these folks
misses the point conspiratorial
perception is real pervasive akin to a
mind virus you might want to try empathy
as in the case of covet victims what the
hell
what is that person talking about
anyway so you can find me on troth
i'm on truth central and it's all really
really weird uh i'll probably end up
banned from there at some point it seems
hard to imagine that i wouldn't all
right everybody so we went to the trump
rally which was an eight minute phone
call we went to the pence rally of which
we saw about five minutes
and that does it i'll be back tomorrow
at 8 pm eastern 24 hours and 45 minutes
from now we will have results from
arkansas
alabama
and georgia the 2022 midterm primaries
continue
and i hope to see everybody very soon
make sure you're following on twitch
make sure you have subscribed on
facebook it's i'm sorry liked on
facebook and subscribed on youtube
it's all free
and we'll see you back here tomorrow